you know I was with you on the since
videos until the Hobbit what that one
was bought so The Hobbit is where you
draw the line you will find with all the
other videos I made but the Hobbit was
so drastically different that you can't
stand it dude you completely ignored the
book exactly and you can't do have this
conversation again
you mean even have a conversation last
time mostly it was generally just you
being a dick or I would say a car hey
car is offensive okay the appropriate
term is Caucasian American I mean it was
in a hole in the ground you complain
about that as a sin
what's next Tale of Two Cities it was
the best of times it was the worst of
times ding is there some movie version
of Tale of Two Cities that I should know
about 1984 hmm it was a bright cold
April morning and the clocks were
striking 13 what kind of stupid clock
strikes 13 ding I wouldn't say that why
not
the Shepherd's gate clock outside the
Royal Observatory in Greenwich strikes
13 strikes 13 every day
it's got Roman numerals 0 through 23 so
if you were to go there I assume you
could confuse 12 o'clock and 7 o'clock
not again how am I supposed to know that
final fantasy had 14 in game you don't
have to know that all you have to know
is that if the Romanum will start with X
7 should be the furthest thing from your
mind and also you should never see a
movie that passed that Roman numeral I
thought Malcolm 10 is pretty good you
can see the first 9 but almost but do
you know about the Shepherd's gate clock
but you don't know about the first line
in The Hobbit book how is that possible
I knew the lineup from The Hobbit book
you knew before I made the video
dude the point is not that they use the
line from the book in movie world they
set up as though the Hobbit book that we
know is something that Bilbo roped to
Frodo which is fine that's cool look at
that but then don't go pull the first
line of the book that says it began in a
hole in the ground because when Frodo
knows it began it all in the ground I
also know why the Eagles didn't take
them all the way to Lonely Mountain yeah
well explained in the movie though what
personally I think it's kind of
Caucasian American of them do not
explain it in the movie as it is it just
seems like Gandalf can summon the Eagles
whenever he needs them and then the
Eagles are just bad at geography yeah
said the guy who said Idaho is not a
real place I just call it Southwest
Montana man the locals want to call it
something different they're more than
welcome to that's their prerogative you
might be more of an asshole than Bobby
Brown dude all right give me a goal and
you go host do I have to oh crap
give me Old Post I'm giving you it's
good okay give me another goal poster no
come on no I'm not doing it it's no fun
to kick without a goalpost you're gonna
have to get used to disappointment I'm
gonna kick it anyway don't kick that
thing at me
[Music]